what about
um
I can't even say without smiling Phil
Hellmuth okay so Phil here's the thing
with Phil he takes it very personally
when I say this
and he doesn't hear the compliment he
only hears the negativity because Phil
wants to be considered the greatest of
all time hashtag positive he wants to be
the greatest of all kinds yes but I'm
like Phil here's the facts you have the
best absolute greatest resume at the
World Series of Poker of anyone in the
world is that not enough right that's
what you have you have that right now do
I think you're the best No Limit holding
player in the world today no do I think
that you know you can play high stakes
mixed games with the best players in the
world today and win no right so he
wouldn't get as much Flack on this topic
if he wasn't so boastful and likes you
know demanding like you never hear Phil
Ivey say I'm the best in the world like
his peers do right but Phil wants to
make the claim and I simply say
I beg to differ right I beg to differ
like I don't think you are the the best
player in the world if we can Linger on
the compliment so he can hear it uh what
makes him so good because uh it seems
like a lot of times his play is not
optimal yeah he definitely has his own
brand of and style of play right he does
not adhere to he's never used a solver
in his life he doesn't know he's not in
that world right he Phil does Phil has a
lot of faith and a lot of confidence in
what he does and that he it will be
successful and I think there's something
to be said about that right he doesn't
ever lack in cell in belief that he can
win and he finds a way to do it his way
and frankly a lot of what he does is
very effective against specific types of
players who are intimidated by him but
whether it's his resume or his demeanor
or his attitude sometimes right like if
you're an average player and then you
know you you beat Phil in a hand you're
gonna hear it this idiot from northern
Europe and beat me in this pot like and
for some people they don't they don't
like that so he can use that uh against
them but I also think too like
he
cares so much
right and that leads to trying really
really hard like he sees these moments
and he doesn't phone him in like
whatever brand of Poker he plays he
tries his best at all times to to
succeed and to win and there's something
to be even though like he's
fundamentally flawed and a lot of things
that he does compared to some of the
bigger players his effort and will and
like his determination to stick around
is you know is is up there and he is
somebody who seems to really hate losing
yes yeah he like you know he he's he's
got a this he feels like he deserves to
win yeah right in all cases and if he
loses it's you know it's not as he joked
around that you and him might do an
anger management uh
is of course